they're preparing for the worst in ohio
police have been ramping up security for
days after fbi warnings that there could
be violent protests around
any or all of the 50 state capitals
we set off to one small community which
is the base for the ohio regular militia
which appear to have strong links to the
oath keepers considered by many
to be one of the most extremist radical
anti-government groups in america today
inside the town almost every house we
saw was bedecked with flags showing
allegiance to donald trump
he has rock solid support here and we
track down several members of the
militia group directly linked to the
storming of the capital
the commander of the local militia is
this woman jessica watkins
seen on the right with her arm on a
fellow militia member
former marine donovan crowl all live in
the same small community
jessica was spotted several times that
day in the crowd sometimes with the oath
keepers militia who described themselves
as defenders of the constitution
but declined to talk to us in this shot
the camera pans round
and we see jessica in the human chain
about to enter
she posted several times that day
herself on the social media platform
parlor
talking about forcing entry into the
building and making it to the senate
her fellow militia member donovan crowl
was also pictured several times
first outside and then inside the
rotunda
slightly obscured but identifiable by
the same markings on his flak jacket
yellow goggles and green buff
donovan crowl wasn't answering our
repeated attempts to contact him
many have gone to ground amid a massive
fbi investigation
into the capital incident but we spoke
to his mother who's been estranged from
her son
for many years i think he should have
faced jail time i mean he broke the law
it pains me to say that but he is not
the same person that i used to know
i mean he's not my sweet boy from years
ago he is
totally done 180 degree and like i said
it breaks my heart to say that
jessica watkins runs a bar in the town
and was also reluctant to talk to us
although those closest to her told us
she sees herself as a patriot who's done
no wrong
some in the community appeared hostile
to the media yeah no i
that you're exactly the sort of person i
want to talk to i don't want to talk to
you
did you agree with what happened at the
capitol that car can get off my property
others were clearly surprised at hearing
of their neighbour's involvement in
washington
uh that was a terrorist group is exactly
what they are they're domestic
terrorists here in the united states
if they don't like the government like i
said they should
some of them are actually living in here
i didn't know that
some of them are the commanders of one
of the groups are living i didn't know
that
that doesn't surprise me at all i i saw
i saw
actions like the capital happening i've
seen that slowly brewing for
four years now and the problem of
right-wing extremism in america
is going to be a massive challenge long
after the inauguration
in towns and cities across the states
alex crawford sky news ohio